The Fast and Furious films have always
been made for a large audience and are
fairly easy to watch all the more reason
for the first of the new Hobson show
some time ago because the scene in which
Luke Hobbs fights his opponents eye out
was too much for the producers instead
the first spin of his aimed at a Peggy
13 age rating in the USA not the
surprise at first but director david
leitch also announced that he has cut
out the tough scenes for the cinema
version yet wants to save them for home
cinema Jason Statham also talks about
the censorship which has caused some
brutal scenes to be cut out in detail he
even talks about the fact that a lot of
things were too x-rated for the movie
which is the highest age rating in the
USA that hasn't been given since 1990
however for fans of the more brutal
entertainment it is likely that these
scenes can be seen on blu-ray at the
latest but before that there will be a
cinema released on August 2nd which
means that we will have to wait a bit
longer for the DVD release the release
of it too is slowly but surely getting
closer in the course of the last weeks
two trailers were released which the
majority of the fans liked very much now
also three pictures have been posted in
advance in a recently published
interview with Collider director Andy
muschietti reveals more details about
the second part of the new edition of it
in the second part the evil clown is
supposed to become even more perverted
and pushed the south proclaim losers
club to its limits with his psycho games
it's no surprise that Pennywise is
supposed to get even worse in the second
part after all he had 27 years to
prepare for his return on the other hand
there are also the meanwhile grown-up
protagonists bill Beverly Ben Ritchie
Eddie and Mike who are determined to
destroy Pennywise perfidious plan a nice
additional info is that it is actually a
she and like in the books she might
produce offspring it will be exciting to
see if the losers Club can defeat it or
if they will literally lose it chapter 2
will be released in cinemas on september
6 2019 soon so the west coast alone will
be back on the screen with his cult
figure John Rambo in the fifth part of
the franchise in an interview last week
he also talked about another popular
film in which he placed the leading role
key this comes as a bit of a surprise as
the 73 year-old salon has repeatedly
announced in the past that he actually
wanted to leave the character Rocky
Balboa behind him now he seems to have
changed his mind as he announced that he
is already working on the script of the
seventh rocky movie similar to Rocky v
the plot will be a bit different from
its predecessors as in the seventh part
Rocky will have to deal with the young
illegal immigrant who is stuck in the
USA the bottom line is that this sounds
very political and salon himself also
thinks that the film will be very
up-to-date unfortunately a release date
isn't fixed yet 35 years after his first
indie action hit Mad Max with Mel Gibson
director George Miller gave his original
film a successor in 2015 the project
which costs about 150 million US dollars
earned about 380 million u.s. dollars
worldwide at the box office and is also
considered by critics to be a successful
action firework at that time Miller also
announced his own Mad Max trilogy with
Tom Hardy but not much has happened
since then in a recently published
interview with indieWIRE Miller explains
that they are just about to solve the
problems of the failed production
however it's pretty clear that a new
movie is coming and it is looking
extremely positive he hasn't said
anything about the more precise date yet
so we'll have to wait a little longer
until we hear more about the sequel of
Mad Max some time ago Andrew Lincoln's
exit from The Walking Dead series caused
a stir they said he wanted to spend more
time with his family but the few days
ago it turned out that Lincoln is
supposed to return as a serial character
Rick Grimes however not in the new
season but at least in his own solo
movie to be seen on the Twitter channel
of AMC at Comic Con though it was mainly
the tenth season and last the film that
played a role which is why a new
announcement about the Walking Dead solo
movie with Rick Grimes is probably not
to be expected at the moment for some
time now cult director Quentin Tarantino
has been talking about retiring after 10
film projects anyone who believes in a
PR gag or something similar is probably
wrong since Tarantino repeated over and
over in past interviews that after 10
movies it would definitely be time to
end only the director's chair of a new
Star Trek film
for him apart from that he really
retires after 10 films number 9 on his
list once upon a time in Hollywood is
about to be released but we do not know
exactly what happens next the script by
Star Trek supposedly already exists but
Tarantino is on the other hand also
interested in Kill Bill 3 we have no
choice but to wait and see when
Tarantino will talk about his new and
last movie four years ago wind Easler
nouns the plan TV series about Riddick
since then nothing has happened a little
surprisingly when diesel now announced
on Instagram that there would be a
Riddick for furia on Instagram he
published the video in which he proudly
holds the script for the new Riddick
film completed by David Bowie in the
camera however it is still uncertain
when the shooting will begin
[Music]